a historic day for the raiders and even
more so the nfl vegas has a new team
president one that could change the
landscape of sports for years to come
it's a great
and historic day to be a raider i'm
proud to introduce to you today the
president of the las vegas raiders
sandra douglas morgan
[Applause]
a new era and a new wall
broken down in the nfl it is not lost on
me that this is a critical and defining
moment in the nfl while sandra douglas
morgan is the first black female team
president in nfl history she's also the
team's third in the last calendar year
after 30 years with the organization
mark bodaine abruptly stepped down his
replacement dan ventrell was fired in
may and soon after came allegations of a
hostile work environment it's no secret
that this organization has faced some
recent challenges
but i want to be clear i am not here to
sweep anything under the rug
or avoid problems or concerns that need
to be addressed
the fact is i accepted this role because
i believe in the promise of the raiders
sandra understands that and she
understands that it's the people first
and that's the kind of culture we're
going to build to build you have to know
and nobody knows vegas better than
morgan a resident for over 40 years an
el dorado high school grad attended unr
and unlv she was the north las vegas
attorney for eight years then was
appointed to the nevada athletic
commission and was recently named the
chair of the gaming control board it's
super emotional because i'm so proud of
her and proud of this accomplishment and
i just got a first-hand view of how hard
she works and i'm 100 confident that the
raiders got the right person for this
job timing is everything in sports and
it's everything in society there's no
better time for sandra douglas morgan to
take over this role that way down the
line this doesn't have to be the first
time for those just like her if i could
be an inspiration or help or open doors
for any other woman and girl out there
then
that's that's an incredible
accomplishment for me
nba summer league tipping off to